well here to tell us more about the
problems surrounding organ donation is
health economist Anika hare she's an
expert on the subject in Germany first
of all that type of technology do you
see that as something happening in the
near future in our lifetime
no one knows actually it's a vision but
it would be great if it was possible
whether or not it it is possible we
don't have it yet
what we do have is too few donors here
in Germany every year we've got a
thousand Germans waiting for it an organ
and dying what can be done to point that
out to people I mean people are really
impressed by this sort of technology
that we're showing but why aren't they
impressed to the extent that they
actually realize they can save lives
already yeah there's a service show that
people are willing to donate organs if
they ask but they don't register as
organ donors so we would need more
information matrons put more
transparency in the system to actually
increase registration rates and there
are different systems about white as the
spanish example is the the leading
example they have an opt-out system
where you have to unregister if you're
not willing to be an organ donor in
germany we have the opt-in system where
you need to register if you want to be
an organ donor that's one difference but
also in in Spain there have been high
investments and implementing organ chord
inators in the hospitals so they
invested a lot in them in your phasing
organ donation rates let's take a look
at Spain because we've got a graph
showing how the Spaniards are world
leaders in this field and it's quite
impressive more than four times as many
Spanish people actually donate organs
than Germans which makes me want to ask
you what's wrong with the Germans who
are usually so socially aware and and
quite progressive in their thinking yes
they are they we say that they need some
more incentives to actually register we
carry organ donor cards and first we
won't need to
registration system there will be one
point but I also we tested in at the
University of Dhaka Dolph attested in
our lab whether we could improve
registration rates with a new system
which is reciprocity so if you register
you get bonus points on the waiting list
once you need to don't earn an organ
yourself and this would help to increase
registration rates for those people who
are willing to donate anyhow so okay so
I guess it's making people aware that
they may someday need an organ
themselves what about these other
systems where I've wanted to perhaps
donate my organ to my partner but
haven't been able to and someone else
can this chain system and has that been
successful it is implemented in the
States and also successful in finding
matches between incompatible pairs and I
have long chains also which which bud
which is technically complicated but in
increased actual donation rates not the
willingness to donate because the people
were willing to donate anyhow but to
find good matches and when you talk
about incentives what about compensation
paying people yeah them internationally
it's a great on that we don't want to
buy organs and to sell organs because
there would be a problem of exploitation
of people in need of monetary meat the
system's already exploited though isn't
it there is one country in the world
Iran they they're you as an living when
you are living in Iran you can buy
kidneys or livers but this is not
working well because these people are
very unhappy like donors are very
unhappy about donations but there are
also other countries like India where
where you can buy even an eye from
someone not legally not legally of
course but but I mean this stuff goes on
we have to be realistic about it
yeah but is this not what we want we
want people to donate as a gift because
yeah but but just lastly what would you
say then to to people who are listening
to this program who may never have
thought about it how do you
or may not even want to how do you
convince them oh that's a good question
I would what we propose is to inform
better about what is a brain death how
is this defined how does the the whole
equation procedure work does the organ
get to the person who really needs an
organ and if you have more information
we can show that then also more people
register and become organ donors okay
hey thank you very much for coming in
thank you